[Musique]
le bridge c'est un peu l'arrière
petit-fils du tarot son histoire remonte
en 1750 les jeux avec des atouts sont
adaptés aux parts ordinaires sous le nom
de triomphe triumph et en espagne tron
en allemand jusqu'à devenir le french
trump en angleterre au fur et à mesure
le jeu évolue mais conserve une
particularité la présence d'une main
visible sur le terrain appelez le mort
on est à la fin du 19e siècle plusieurs
variantes existent mais une va
l'emporter sur les autres le bridge
contrat mais pourquoi ce nom le bridge
et bien tout simplement parce que tout
bride signifie jeter un pont en anglais
c'est choisir d'enchérir sur la toux ou
laisser le choix à son partenaire de jeu
l'action de base pour lancer une partie
le bridge se joue à quatre joueurs avec
un paquet de 52 cartes chaque joueur
représente un point cardinal et joue
avec le joueur d'en face nord avec sud
est avec west le but d'une partie marqué
le plus de points possible chacun
possède 13 cartes qu'ils en donnent en
couleurs une fois les bases posées on
passe aux enchères
il faut trouver le meilleur contrat
réalisables à partir d'un minimum de
cette levée remporté sur les treize
possibles chacun son tour il faut donner
une enchère supérieure à la précédente
où passer la main dès que trois joueurs
passent consécutivement la dernière
équipe à enchérir commence avec le
contre
une fois cette phase d'enchères terminé
on entame la partie sans oublier le mort
le coéquipier du joueur devant remplir
le contrat étale ses gains face à lui et
c'est son partenaire qui va lui dicter
son choix à chaque tour pour chaque
bonne c'est la plus grosse carte qui
l'emportent les joueurs sont obligés de
mettre des cartes de la même couleur que
la première carte jouée si on n'a pas la
couleur on place un atout ou n'importe
quelle autre carte pour compter les
points à la fin d'une donne chaque
joueur récupère sa carte et la place de
façon verticale ou horizontale selon
s'il a gagné ou perdu on recommence la
manoeuvre 13 fois à la fin de compte et
on voit si le contrat a été rempli